bridgerton the show that stole 16 hours
of my life that i actually enjoyed for
those of you who don't know what
bridgeton is it's an alternate
historical drama series that follows the
bridgerton family as they search for
love during the season in high london
society when my wife asked me to watch
this show with her i thought fine i'll
watch it but i'll probably play on my
phone or not pay much attention but boy
was i wrong i was fully engaged for two
eight hour plus long seasons bridgette
has a peculiar way of keeping you
entertained while not really providing
much substance it is as i would call it
a mesmerizing mess
[Music]
before we get into it obviously there
will be spoilers for the show so if
you're worried about it being spoiled
watch the show first then come back to
this video okay so first of all i don't
intend to talk about the plot of the
show that much in this video instead
i'll be talking about themes and how the
series is able to pull people in and not
let them go until they've watched every
single episode but how exactly does the
show keep people so captivated the three
main reasons audiences are so mesmerized
by bridgerton are character investment
tension and high stakes each season
introduces us to a new set of characters
with the bridgertons the featheringtons
and the duke of hastings being
introduced in the first season and the
sharma family being introduced in the
second season we're also introduced to a
mystery character named lady whistled
down who with the help of her almost
daily gossip pamphlet has about as much
social power as the queen of england
herself the writers for the show do an
excellent job of getting the audience
invested in each of the characters
struggles and desires in a way that i
haven't seen much before in television
shows it's because of this investment
that we quickly start to care what
happens to the bridge or tens of the
featheringtons and the sharmas and the
over-the-top drama that ensues between
them for example we care a lot when
daphne finds out simon can have children
but that he just doesn't want any we
care when lady whistle down's identity
is almost revealed and we care so much
when we come to understand why anthony
and kate just can't be together to
someone who hasn't gotten invested into
these characters and their stories these
things would probably seem insignificant
but to those who have been pulled into
the show's drama you can't help but feel
empathy for the characters the show is
also quite good at creating tension by
only giving the audience certain pieces
of information and not the entire story
the tension begins to rise in very tense
situations we don't know what's gonna
happen we simply hope for the best
outcome but expect the worst for example
when anthony and kate come close to
kissing multiple times when we know they
absolutely should not part of us still
hopes that they do because we know the
love and passion they share for each
other these scenes in particular do a
great job of building tension across
episodes until they finally all come
together the underlying reason we get
such tense scenes though is because the
writers have already set such high
stakes for the characters having the
story set in a partially historical
1800s england the stakes are very high
for the young lords and ladies of london
especially during this season it's well
established that a gentleman and a lady
must not ever be alone together without
a chaperone since they could be doing
something that might taint the lady's
honor it's also established that all
ladies must find a husband or else
they'll turn into an old spinster with
no one to take care of them lastly it's
established that all gentlemen must find
a wife so that they can do their duty in
furthering their family's line by having
a son because the scene is set with such
stringent rules and expectations the
stakes are very high for all of our main
characters for example anytime two
characters of opposite sexes are in a
room alone you're always afraid someone
will burst into the room and find them
together right before demanding that
they get married because they were alone
together also you understand just how
important to the characters it is to
find a spouse not just for love but for
all the previously mentioned reasons
when even a single member of one of the
high-class london families doesn't
follow every single social rule they're
shunned from society so the stakes are
at their highest during the season in
which both seasons of bridgerton take
place now that we understand exactly why
bridgeton is so mesmerizing let's dive
into the mess of a show we received and
i don't necessarily mean mess in a bad
way instead i would liken it to a high
production quality much better version
of a soap opera set in 1800s england it
actually has very good dialogue and
writing likely due to the fact that it's
based on a book series of the same name
and many people know that series based
on books with good writing can often
have great results until they run out of
source material and start to crash and
burn like game of thrones anyways there
were several things about the show that
i didn't really like first of all the
way the characters talk can be a little
infuriating at times like whenever they
say mamas and papas i cannot stand it
also i was pretty let down when we found
out that lady whistledown was not
actually julie andrews but penelope i
mean come on i would love to see mary
poppins in this show also penelope was
probably one of my least favorite
characters so making her the secret
writer that's been narrating the entire
season was a huge letdown one thing i
actually really liked about the show
though was its use of classical music
covers of modern pop songs the show's
director and executive producer julianne
robinson said the music covers were
inspired by the use of classic rock
songs in the 2001 heath ledger film a
knight's tale hearing classical covers
of thank you next bad guy and even
wildest dreams was a bit surreal but i
enjoyed it a lot i think bridgerton will
likely become a guilty pleasure of mine
in the future since i'll probably have
to re-watch it when season 3 comes out
to those who haven't already seen
bridgerton i don't know if i would
necessarily recommend watching it if you
have an extra 16 hours and it sounds
interesting enough then get ready for a
completely unexpected roller coaster of
emotions that you won't be able to turn
away from although the show was a bit of
a mess i certainly think it will
continue to grow in popularity
mesmerizing audiences around the world
anyways that's gonna be all for today if
you like what you saw maybe check out
the video on your screen for some
different content i make videos on
basically anything that interests me in
the world of entertainment also don't
forget to like and subscribe as it truly
does help me out and thanks for watching
rocket riley
you